you think aliens are half sentience
and if they do how do we think about it
so when you have this framework what is
this paper what is what is the way you
propose to think about Essentials yeah
that that particular paper was was a
very short um commentary on another
paper that was written about crabs
there's a really good paper on them uh
crabs and and various like like a rubric
of uh of different types of behaviors
that that could be applied to different
creatures and they're trying to apply it
to crabs and so on them I I've
Consciousness we can talk about a
feeling but it's a whole separate kettle
of fish I I I almost never talk about
crabs in this case yes I almost never
talk about Consciousness per se I've
said very very little about it but we
can we can talk about it if you want
mostly what I talk about is is cognition
because I think that that's much easier
to deal with in a um kind of rigorous
experimental experimental way I think
that um all of these all of these terms
have uh you know sentience and and so on
have different definitions and I
fundamentally I think that people can as
long as they specify what they mean
ahead of time
um I think people can Define them in
various ways the one the the the the
only thing that I really kind of insist
on is that
the right way to think about all this
stuff is is an energy from an
engineering perspective what does it
help me to to control predict and uh and
does it help me do my next experiment so
so so so so that that's that's not a
universal perspective so some people
have uh philosophical kind of
underpinnings and those are primary and
if anything runs against that then it
must automatically be wrong so so some
people will say I don't care what else
if your theory says to me that
thermostats have little tiny goals I'm
not I'm not I'm not so that's it I just
like that's my philosophical you know
preconception that like thermostats do
not have goals and that's it so um so
that's one way of doing it and some
people do it that way I do not do it
that way and I think that we can't if we
we can't I don't think we can know much
of anything from our from a
philosophical armchair I think that all
of these theories and ways of doing
things stand or fall based on just just
basically one set of criteria does it
help you run a rich research program
that's it if I agree with you totally
but so forget philosophy what about the
Poetry of ambiguity what about at the
limits of the things you can engineer
using terms that are that can be defined
in multiple ways
and living within that yeah
uncertainty in order to play with words
until something lands that you can
engineer I mean that's to me where
Consciousness sits currently nobody
really understands the the hard problem
of Consciousness is the subject what it
feels like because it really feels like
it feels like something to be this
biological system this conglomerate of a
bunch of cells in this hierarchy of
competencies feels like something and
yeah I feel like one thing and is that
just
is that just the as a side effect of a
complex system
or is there something more
that humans have or is there something
more than any biological system has some
kind of magic some kind of not just the
sense of agency
but a real sense with a capital letter s
of agency yeah uh boy uh yeah that's a
deep question is there room for poetry
and Engineering or no no there
definitely is and a lot of the Poetry it
comes in when we realize that none of
the categories we deal with are sharp as
we think they are right and so and so in
the you know in the different areas of
of all these Spectra are where a lot of
the Poetry sits I have many new theories
about things but I in fact do not have a
a good theory about Consciousness that I
plan to trot out so and you almost don't
see it as useful for your current work
unconsciousness I think it will come I
have some thoughts about it but I don't
feel like they're going to move the
needle yet on that but then you want to
ground in in engineering always
so well
I mean I don't so so so so if we really
tackle Consciousness per se in terms of
the hard problem I don't I don't that
that isn't necessarily going to be
groundable in engineering right that
that aspect of the cognition is but
actual Consciousness per se you know for
first person perspective I'm not sure
that that's groundable in engineering
and I think specifically what's
different about what's different about
it is there's a couple things so so
let's you know here we go I'll say a
couple things about about Consciousness
one one thing is that what makes it
different is that for every other type
aspect of science
when we think about having a correct or
a good theory of it we have some idea of
what format it that theory makes
predictions in so whether those be
numbers or whatever we we have some idea
we may not know the answer we may not
have the theory but we know that when we
get the theory here's what it's going to
output and then we'll know if it's right
or wrong for actual Consciousness not
Behavior not neural correlates but
actual first person Consciousness if we
had a correct Theory Of Consciousness or
even a good one what the hell would what
what format would would it make
predictions in right because because all
the things that we know about it
basically boil down to observable
behaviors so the only thing I can think
of when I think about that is is is
it'll be poetry or it'll be it'll be
it'll be something to um if if I ask you
okay you've got a great Theory Of
Consciousness and here's this here's
this creature maybe it's a natural maybe
it's an engineer one whatever and I want
you to tell me what your theory says
about this this beings um what it's like
to be this being the only thing I can
imagine you giving me is some piece of
art a poem or or something that once
I've taken it in I share I I I I now
have a similar State as whatever that's
that's about as good as I can come up
with well it's possible that that once
you have a good understanding of
Consciousness it would be mapped to some
things that are more measurable so for
example it's possible that
a conscious being is one that's able to
suffer
so you start to look at pain and
suffering you can start to connect it
closer to
things that
you can measure that in terms of how
they reflect themselves in Behavior
and problem solving and uh creation and
attainment of goals for example which I
think suffering is one of the you know
life is suffering it's one of the one of
the big aspects of the The Human
Condition
and so if Consciousness is somehow a
maybe at least a catalyst for suffering
you could start to get like Echoes of it
and you start you you start to see like
the actual effects of Consciousness and
behavior that it's not just about
subjective experience it's like it's
really deeply integrated in the problem
solving uh decision making of a system
uh something like this but also it's
possible that we realize this is not a
philosophical statement philosophers can
write their books I welcome it uh you
know I I take the touring test really
seriously I I don't know why people
really don't like it
when a robot convinces you that it's
intelligent I think that's a really
incredible accomplishment and there's
some deep sense in which that is
intelligence
if it looks like it's intelligent it is
intelligent and I think there's some
deep aspect
of um a system that appears to be
conscious it
in some deep sense it is conscious
for these for me we have to consider
that possibility and a system that
appears to be conscious
is an engineering challenge
yeah I don't disagree with any of that I
mean especially intelligence I think is
a publicly observable thing I I and and
I mean you know science fiction has
dealt with this for a century or or much
more maybe uh this idea that when you
are confronted with something that just
doesn't meet any of your typical
assumptions so you can't look in the
skull and say oh well there's that
frontal cortex so then I guess we're
good right if it's if it's you know so
so this thing lands on your front lawn
and this you know with the the little
door opens and something trundles out
and it's sort of like
um you know kind of shiny and aluminum
looking and it hands you this uh you
know it hands you this poem that it
wrote while it was on you know flying
over and how happy it is to meet you
like what's going to be your criteria
right for whether whether you get to
take it apart and see what makes a tick
or whether you have to you know be nice
to it and and whatever right like all
the all the criteria that we have now
and you know that people are using and
then as you said a lot of people are
down on the touring tests and things
like this but but what else have we got
you know because measuring measuring a
quart exercise isn't gonna isn't gonna
cut it right in the broader scheme of
things so uh I think this is it's it's a
wide open it's a wide open problem that
right that we you know our our solution
to the problem of other Minds it's very
simplistic right we we give each other
credit for having Minds just because we
sort of on uh you know on an anatomical
level we're pretty similar and then so
that's good enough but how how far is
that going to go so I think that's
really primitive so um yeah I think I
think it's a major unsolved problem it's
a really challenging
uh direction of thought to the human
race
uh that you talked about like embodied
Minds if you start to think that other
things other than humans have Minds
that's really challenging yeah because
all men are created equal starts
starts being like all right well we
should probably treat
not just cows with respect yeah but like
plants and not just plants but
uh some kind of organized conglomerates
of cells in a petri dish
in fact some of the work we're we're
doing like you're doing and the whole
community of science is doing with
Biology people might be like we weren't
really mean to viruses yeah
I mean yeah I the thing is you're right
and and I get I get I certainly get
phone calls about uh people complaining
about frog skin and so on but
I think we have to separate the sort of
deep philosophical aspects versus what
actually happened so what actually
happens on Earth is that people with
exactly the same anatomical structure
kill each other you know on a daily
basis right so so so it I think it's
clear that simply knowing that something
else is equally or maybe more uh
cognitive or conscious than you are is
is not a guarantee of of of kind
behavior that that much we know of so
then and so then then we look at a
commercial farming of mammals and
various other things and so so I think
on a practical basis long before we get
to worrying about
um things like frog skin we have to ask
ourselves why are we uh what what can we
do about the way that we've been
behaving towards creatures which we know
for a factor because of our similarities
are are basically just like us you know
that's kind of a whole other this is a
social thing but but but fundamentally
you know of course you're absolutely
right in that we we are also think about
this we are on on this planet in some
way incredibly lucky it's just dumb luck
that we really only have one dominant
species it didn't have to work out that
way so you could easily imagine that
there could be a planet somewhere with
more than one equally or maybe near
equally intelligent species and then uh
but but then they may not look anything
like each other right so there may be
multiple ecosystems where there are uh
things of of similar to human-like
intelligence and then you'd have all
kinds of issues about you know how do
you how do you relate to them when
they're physically not like you at all
but yet yet you know in terms of
behavior and culture and whatever it's
pretty obvious that the that they've got
as you know as much on the ball as you
have or maybe imagine imagine that there
was another
um group of beings that was like on
average you know 40 IQ points lower
right like like we're just we're pretty
lucky in many ways we you know we don't
really have even though we we sort of
you know we still act badly in many ways
but but but the fact is you know all
humans are more or less in this like in
the same that same range but didn't have
to work out that way well but I think
that's part of the way life works on
Earth uh maybe human civilization works
is it seems like we want us ourselves to
be quite similar
and then within that you know what
everybody's about the same relatively IQ
intelligence problem solving
capabilities even physical
characteristics
but then we'll find some aspect of that
as different and that seems to be like
I mean it's it's really dark to say but
that seems to be the
I'm not even a bug but like a feature
of
the early development of human
civilization you pick the other your
tribe versus the other tribe in your War
it's a kind of evolution evolution in
the space of of memes a space of ideas I
think and you warp with each other so
we're very good at finding the other
even when the characteristics are really
the same that's I don't know what
that I mean I'm sure so many of these
things echo in the biological World in
some way yeah there's a fun um
experiment that uh I did my my son
actually came up with this so we we did
um a a biology unit together he would
use so homeschool and so we did this a
couple years ago we did this thing where
it imagines you get the sly mold right
and polycephalum and it grows on them uh
on a uh on a petri dish of agar and it
sort of spreads out and and it's it's
it's a single cell you know protist but
it's like this giant thing and so you
put down a piece of oat and it wants to
go get the oat and it sort of grows
towards the oat so what you do is you
take a razor blade and you just you just
separate the piece of the whole culture
that's growing towards the the oh you
just kind of separate it and so now
think about think about the interesting
decision-making calculus for that little
piece I can I can go get the oat and
therefore I won't have to share those
nutrients with this giant mass over
there so the so the nutrients per unit
volume is going to be amazing so I
should go ethio
but if I first rejoin because faizaram
once you cut it has the ability to join
back up if I first rejoin then that
whole calculus becomes impossible
because there is no more me anymore
there's just we and then and then we
will go eat this thing right so so this
interesting you know this is you can
imagine a kind of game theory where the
number of Agents isn't fixed and that
it's not just cooperator defect but it's
actually merge and and whatever right
yeah so that kind of that that
competition how does it do that decision
making yeah so so that right so so it's
it's really interesting and so and so
empirically what we found is that it
tends to merge first it tends to merge
first and then the whole thing goes but
but it's really interesting that that
that that that that calculus like do we
even have I mean I'm not an expert in
the economic Game Theory and all that
but maybe there's a cat maybe some sort
of hyperbolic discounting or something
but but maybe you know this idea that
the the actions you take not only change
your payoff but they change who or what
you are and that you may not you you
could take an action after which you
don't exist anymore or you are radically
changed or you are merged with somebody
else like that's you know as far as I
know that's a whole you know we're still
missing a formalism for even knowing how
to how to model any of that